after a day of intensive talks rail
workers will get to vote on a pay offer
but their union doesn't want them to
accept it
the rnt union today has decided to put a
new offer from Network rail
two members in an electronic referendum
with a recommendation to reject the
proposals from Network rail also put
further strike action that will take
place and all members will be instructed
not to book on from 1800 hours on
December the 24th until six o'clock in
the morning on December the 27th what do
you think the traveling public would
would the chance given but
the disruption
marketing companies will be indemnified
for all of their losses so my members
will lose money a lot of money as you've
set out
the public will lose the convenience of
having a train service the businesses
around here and all around London and
all over the country will lose money
undoubtedly the only people that won't
lose money are the train operating
companies
the electronic vote by rmt members will
close on Monday too late to prevent
disruption to services from Strike
action already planned for the following
two days even if they accept the pay
offer we've made sure that there was a
new improved payoff which I think is
fair to rmt members what is
disappointing is the fact that the rmt
not only of not called off strikes
they've actually called more strikes for
the Christmas period And I would urge
them to call those strikes off
the RMV civilized ministers are
directing this dispute but their move
reflects pressure to offer members who
face losing four days paid through
strike action this month a vote on a
deal worth five percent for this year
and four percent for next a second offer
from train operators has been rejected
out of hand however while talks continue
resolution looks a long way off
additional strikes for three days from
Christmas Eve will only add to
disruption I think it's kind of a bit of
a pain as a customer but also we should
be paying people what they deserve to be
paid well I'm supposed to be visiting
him him on the 26th so
the Train's operating I don't know what
I'm going to do it's particularly
difficult for me because I don't drive
um but I can appreciate it must be quite
difficult for those staff as well and
they're sacrificing something themselves
the rmt's move came as staff at Green
King walked out in their own dispute
overpay an example of organized labor in
a brewery that could blow the froth of
Christmas celebrations their wages have
not kept pace with the cost of living or
inflation because they've lost this 21
in real terms over such a long period of
time you know that they're they're
living you know on the breadline
basically what do you want
nurses will strike this month too and
teachers may follow in the new year with
inflation running at record levels
ministers and employers argue keeping up
is impossible for workers it's proving
the Last Straw
Kelso Sky News